on your left
it was amazing yes it felt like
relatively early on in the lockdown in
the pandemic that that clip
uh from inside the audiences at avengers
end game
uh first theatrical run um
uh went viral and the people cheering
for the
on your left moment and when the portals
came uh opened up
it was wonderful because it reminded me
of
of endgame and the year before
uh i think i was in one of those
theaters where that was uh
where somebody had recorded that so that
that that feeling was very special
but coming in the midst of this pandemic
when we had spent so much
time in our homes uh not surrounded by
other people it was a wonderful reminder
of
of community and of a shared
exp a shared experience and certainly
we've all shared the pandemic
experience apart but that clip did take
on i think new meaning
even for me personally during uh down
last year not just a memory of
of the year before and and the wonderful
uh achievement that the russo brothers
and
our entire cast and everybody marvel
studios pulled off with endgame
but a promise of the future and of being
in a theater again
and uh and uh having a shared experience
like that some someday in the future i
think it gave us
it gave us hope avengers
[Applause]
every time we make a film it is it is
with the expectation of delivering on an
ex
delivering on on um
on a promise delivering on a promise of
uh of a uh
experience um a to be experienced
together in a theater
and seeing where people laugh or seeing
where people
um get very quiet and still
or where people cheer if we should be so
lucky in moments in the movie
that is we spent years and years uh
trying to work up to those moments and
being in a theater and seeing it
and seeing it happen there's nothing
better so every decision we make
is from the point of view of sitting in
a crowded theater
experiencing the the story
a lot of choosing what characters what
stories go
uh become a feature film first what
become a disney plus series
it's still frankly early days for that
so we're still having those discussions
what you see now in in in phase four
is still the culmination of of work five
or six years
in the case of shanxi 10 or 15 years in
the past so we have been working towards
the shangshi movie
for many many years towards a black
widow movie as everybody knows
for many many years so those were always
said on
uh as films of what we wanted them what
we wanted them to be
when when when bob iger told us about
disney plus and about
um his desire for us to to to
produce shows for disney plus it gave us
a new avenue
frankly to to do something we hadn't
been considering
before which was really doing a deep
dive on characters who deserve
a deep dive but hadn't uh um i had the
chance yet
you know we it took us four or five
films to uh to tell even a tiny story of
wanda maximoff and the vision same thing
with sam wilson
and bucky barnes it's a testament to
those characters and particularly to
those actors
that the audience fell in love with them
in what really amounted to a relatively
short amount of screen time
uh in a handful of films but we knew
they were being underutilized
um both the characters and the actors
and we really wanted to have a
showcase to uh to to show off how
amazing those characters are
and how amazing those those actors are
and certainly uh tom hiddleston is loki
as well and also to to do it in a way
in a new medium and do it in a way that
that we couldn't couldn't be done
in uh in a feature film
[Applause]
i think we've always at marvel studios
tried to
swing for the fences on every project
treat every project
like it it was our last like when we
were making iron man one
if that hadn't worked it would have been
our first and last movie that marvel
studios made
and when the choice of robert downey jr
came up it really felt make or break it
really felt like
we have nothing to lose because we're
not a studio yet anyway
and if we only have one chance to do it
we want to do it right
and even though he hadn't been a marquee
star before he was an incredible
incredible actor
and we were very lucky that he that he
wanted to do it um
so every decision since then has kind of
been treated the same of how do we swing
for the fences how do we do something
unique how do we as i said earlier um
meet or exceed expectations but
oftentimes that's by subverting
those expectations and selfishly
keeping ourselves entertained i'm going
on my 21st year
at marvel studios the majority of our
team has been together 10 years 15 years
and we want to do all different types of
stories and make all different types of
uh
of um of uh films and now series
so so with guardians of the galaxy and
doctor strange and
shane black's iron man three and take it
with td thor ragnarok
uh we've always tried to bring in new
unique voices and ryan coogler's
black panther it goes on and on with the
disney plus series we need we've been
able to do that but within a new medium
so suddenly instead of just
riffing off of um cinematic genres
we could go into the specifics of of
tv procedurals like loki is a bit of an
homage to and
certainly and most uh clearly with one
division in the sitcom uh and the sitcom
tropes
oh hello dear i'm agnes your neighbor to
the right
my right not yours forgive me catherine
han has been a phenomenon long before
wanda vision and we were all fans of
hers at uh at the marvel studios and she
had come in for a general
meeting coincidentally right around the
time we were trying to cast
uh agnes slash agatha and
it was one of those you know
why didn't we think of this before uh
that
oh we met with catherine hahn today she
was great ludi esposito actually sat
down um
and had a general with her and it very
quickly went from that she's great
what could she do for us someday anyway
who's going to play agatha we really got
to cast this part
wait a second it was it was honestly
almost exactly like that seeing
audiences respond for characters
that the two characters they were not
expecting or that they were not asking
for i wouldn't say there was a huge
contingency of people
banging down the door for agatha
harkness to appear in the mcu
but she's a great character portrayed by
a great actress
and by the first few episodes people are
asking where is she going to show up
again what else is she gonna do
i think the same thing's happening right
now with john walker from the from the
falcon winter soldier series and
certainly with mobius m mobius as
portrayed by owen wilson in the loki's
series
so that is something that is so
important to the mcu is including new
characters
the comic is filled with many lifetimes
of spectacular characters
uh and when you find the best actors to
portray them
uh it can quickly go from from an
audience
never hearing of a character to them
uh upset with us that we haven't already
announced their own standalone
uh movie and that makes us all very
happy this is chaos magic wanda
that makes you the scarlet [ __ ]
the supernatural sorcery with dr strange
which you saw
not only in his movie but in infinity
war and endgame
um and and explaining the powers that
we'd seen
uh wanda have throughout the movies now
having
this connection to witchcraft and and
magic
um again right from the marvel comics
it's always been there
uh it's fun to be able to figure out a
way to to bring more of that into the
mcu
that's the black falcon there i tell you
now that's captain america of primary
importance was
allowing anthony mackie to um
to show the full range of what anthony
mackie can do such an amazing
amazing actor and same thing with
sebastian stan as uh
as bucky barnes but when old man steve
rogers handed the shield
to sam wilson at the end of end game you
could see
a complexity in anthony's performance
there old man cap says how does it feel
and sam says like it belongs somebody
else and and old man steve says
you know doesn't it's yours and that it
wouldn't be that simple
it wouldn't be that simple for anyone to
step into those shoes
um that steve rogers had worn but
particularly for sam wilson
wearing the red white and blue in
america would be would be complex
and and that is what we were interested
in exploring that's what anthony was
interested in exploring
um uh our fellow producers zoe and nate
moore
uh and and thankfully when malcolm
spellman our head writer came on
is really when all of that um um
it turned into the series that that you
saw um
a series that he had written with his
with his uh uh
writing staff um before
the pandemic we started shooting that
before lockdown so in 2019
and people some people have asked um
were you surprised that it became even
more relevant after 2020 what we've gone
through
and and certainly what malcolm says is
well it was relevant
in 2019 as well it's been relevant for
for hundreds of years
which is exactly correct and figuring
out a way to both
wear the red white and blue with pride
and acknowledge the past at the same
time
seemed like a uh interesting needle to
thread and one that we needed
filmmaker like kari skoglyn and writer
like malcolm spellman and his team to
to pull off is that funny the idea that
your little club decides the fate of
trillions of people across all of
existence at the behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
i thought you didn't like to talk well
you know i think everything we do
um i i hope are building blocks towards
the bigger
the bigger mcu while actually just being
entertainment
entertaining pieces of art in and of
themselves the loki series
um explores an organization that
that we've been obsessed with uh for
years at marvel studios from
from the comics called the time variant
authority
and honestly 15 20 years ago going this
is a great idea i wonder if we could
ever do something with this
and honestly thinking it was a pipe
dream that would never would never
come to fruition avengers was a pipe
dream uh uh
20 years ago and now that we have this
series
that uh that our producer kevin wright
and and our director kate herron and our
head writer michael waldron
uh and executive producer tim broussard
have have taken the tva conceit that
we've loved so much
and turn it into uh an entirely
different way of looking at the mcu and
looking at the timeline
of the mcu and yes the potential of
of alternate realities that we've heard
whispers of from the ancient one and
from
other characters in a few of our movies
but actually being able to explore it
and try to understand it in a again
rather subversive way in a bureau in a
very bureaucratic organization
that may or may not be telling the truth
about the way things work
um uh in in a character's
the title character also being someone
who you shouldn't necessarily take at
face value
and is perhaps the most famous uh uh
trickster or god of mischief that there
is
varian l one one thirty aka loki
laufen is charged with sequence
violation 720.89
how do you plead
madam a god doesn't plead tom is it's
great an actor as they come he's as
charismatic
a person as there is but he also
honestly
loves that he's been given this chance
and that from the moment we hired him
with ken branagh on the first thor
film to uh the response that episode
three got
uh the other the other week when it
debuted on disney plus tom
is just as enthusiastic from that first
call to each episode of loki coming out
and that is so important i think all of
us at marvel studios
uh um try to maintain that enthusiasm
and
acknowledgement and humility of how
lucky we are to be in this position
and tom can take that with his immense
amount of talent
and really rally a crew behind him as
well which is what he did on that show
so one of the other things that's that
that personally is so exciting about
about continuing a franchise for this
long is getting to evolve
um uh your relationship with the with
the cast
tom started as a as a as an actor that
ken brown on new
who as people may know famously
auditioned not for loki but for thor
then you know felt very thankful to get
this job as uh
as loki i now find myself thankful that
he said yes
and that he is an executive producer on
this loki series and is helping us make
this series what it is so
so relationships evolving um over the
years is one of the other great
pleasures of working with spectacular
talents like that
um and that's true on on uh films like
black widow that scarlett johansson was
a producer on with us as well
and uh all of the disney plus series
your prince
must have been would be princesses
or perhaps another prince
a bit of both representation is
important
across the board and the comics has
charted um uh you know charts the path
in almost all ways for what we do in the
mcu and
in the comics there are many lgbtq
characters and we want to showcase that
on the screen as well we want to bring
those characters to life on the screen
we also as as stan lee uh used to say
marvel represents the world outside your
window and outside of our window
there are uh um all different types of
people
in all different types of places with
all different types of preferences
and we want that reflected in the mcu
and in our and in our
in our fictional world as it is in our
in our real world uh so it is of utmost
importance
that when people go in and see one of
our films or
uh log on to disney plus and watch one
of our series that it represents
uh the true world outside their window
when it comes to the the to the types of
people
portraying the heroes and the characters
[Music]
scarlett johansson is just the perfect
representation of
of an amazing amazing actor
lending their talents to our stories for
a decade
that is an amazing privilege and one
that we don't that we don't ever take
for granted she's
she was nominated for two academy awards
in one year
a few years ago she is spectacular and
could do whatever she wants
that she chooses um to continue to work
and to bring natasha romanoff to life
is a is a testament i think to the
character of natasha
and how rich she is in the comics and
how much more there was to explore and a
testament to scarlett
who likes uh bringing these complex
characters to life
so it really is kind of the a perfect
representation
of of when you find a perfect actor
willing to dedicate their talents to an
amazing character from publishing
that that you can go you can go 10 years
on and be on the verge of
of their first standalone movie and and
thankfully our first movie in a theater
in almost two years
that uh that i i just can't wait for
people to see
in a uh uh in a theater on disney plus
if they want
um but to get out there and see what
scarlet and the entire team has done
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and cover my plan was to drive
us away
glorious plan sucks florence is is
amazing and came in and
won the part of elena elena is the
character it's been the comics for many
years now and a character that we'd
wanted to bring to the screen
for quite a while uh soon after we cast
her i think she was nominated for little
women which was amazing
and again like scarlett being able to
traverse these worlds of
um of uh uh
you know classic literature like little
women
and moving over to what we consider also
classic literature
of uh of the marvel comics and do both
with
equal uh import and with equal pouring
of their heart and soul into it
um which which everybody all of our
filmmakers and our writers and the
entire team marvel studios do
florence did that tremendously well and
like some of the other characters we've
talked about today yes the very first
question that often comes out of people
seeing black widow for the first time
is when will florence pugh show up again
in the mcu
and my answer to that is is always not
soon enough um
because she's amazing another testament
to scarlett
um who who knew exactly the movie
that that we were making who was a part
of the development of the movie to make
that film an ensemble and to surround
herself with new
with new characters portrayed by new
actors entering the mcu
and allowing them all to shine um uh
and knowing that lifting them up lifts
up the whole movie which is what a smart
producer does which scarlett is
um so it is great so every compliment
that florence or david or rachel
or ot get on a movie um
i also turn back to scarlet for being uh
for being um so smart to to um
allow the film to to be a showcase for
multiple characters which is what the
best
of uh of our films can do
you